ah r came up
a
whole what can't you do
ams axel two top cg ram cheap
hour on to i
wrote ah ah this minor yuma
ipai honey ah ah i can call you i can
pick a child i need flaxseed like this
scores ah yu
lele the guest is already going to
dust show  When it rots,
green
wall decisive battle HD
Calming Cook who did high one on both sides of the island. Since I
was young, actually, I was originally an actor
.
It was my dream to do it
[Music] I
was bored and worked out all the time
, how are you? I immigrated to the United States and my
house was a bit difficult in 6, so I work a lot because I was poor
.  And
then
, by chance, I got a
full audition for a movie, and through a friend’s
introduction, I prepared and operated China because of the English ode Sherlock,
and after 5
movies, I did a little play
when I was very young.
That monthly rent  I
was already doing a garage play when I was doing 5 ping,
but then my friend asked
me while working on
this unmanned
gestus.  As I
became more and more, I had a dream for another work about acting,
and it came again, came to the fire,
and I think crabs came too
. Well, tell
me well.  I thought it was
Mr. Hak-seong, but when I was a man exr overseas,
I didn't know that the plant department
would become so
world-famous
.  After that, it
seemed like the Hollywood movie Upper came in quietly to me,
so
I
came in and wrote a
lot of as if
col, and I wrote
it at the right time.
Mr. Yes Season 6 Uh Payment was a little bit
very good and drank well After that,
why were you a fan of
Ouija?
Wan is
Chimo Natural Written Uh Penn y1 I think Megumi is having fun y
I have to make a plan
Uh
Well, they are so great directors and
producers
I think I'll make it very fun I think I can make it more
fun
b2 Then now let
's get a zombie about a Korean style
Ju Tucson,
but now,
I think I need to come out with some Glover-style scholars. A few
airs below.
See u are 8 votes and how.
Personnel gangster carpet crocodile
again ok vpr Ai She
prepares it all the same Uh uh
I'm just
preparing some eggs for a specific movie '
cause I always do action movies Oh my
student and I still spar
and
uh
spar  I'm still holding welly meetings saying "Hurry up, more quickly"
, and I'm still doing welly meetings,
and there's a
lot of doubt that I'll be next, so I'm doing thawing together on top of
that, but now he's different from
real action.
So I fight
in the air, uh, with
4 magicinations, saying that the size will be this
big, uh, bizarre earphones are not hot,
uh, because I have to fight with imagination, that's it
It's a little different Yes it's hard Yes it's a little
bit
new and interesting I think it
's the 3rd departure of Pika Underground Nuclear 3rd I
'm going to be discouraged
Composer Catch a square version I made a day
1 Shiny Ding oh Yes I always did that because I'm with
the Air Korea Grass again
Because we do design and action design together
, that
's different. Actors and other
people teach us a lot, and we
have
to not get hurt on set, so
don't get hurt.
Then, but fiercely, they
teach us how to fight, and then
, like that, hey action team.
I do a lot of action and design a lot and I
'm working like that on
one hand and a
[Music]
Mystery I have to use the
server to eat the
OT  4 and finish Venus Tight Duct
2nd
come back opera Ah ah's Wall Lai ngn i born Final ticket Come earlier Sounds
that can't even be
noticed A blank disc written on cd2
ok Elle Dina ball Come see me
Adigui Loupe Pearl shouting Ring 9 10
Where are you  Super
milk 2nd place Play v No freeware No
naphtha Oh I don’t use it I’m at the high tab Faker
center erm
Excitium Shen Amumu Rare
nwc shot meaning Market’s skill 3 Something
already done Center Taniyama Right at that
time, he gave up his mind  You say you
can stay uh
rsa ya ya
meteo ye ji out of habit what shi
win win Seoul misfires
without applause 5 suck woo child stay rice
kicks in cause address 4 so i'm
well second or not Expensive marks sister
space essay's  I can't stop it
so much It's like this
You have to audition for a tea that shoots seo cream
uh I'm very proud of it uh now I'm very proud of
Korean
uh
I also have a lot of notes but it's
really good I do every end and
there's a lot of good content so
now it's a
speed game and a lot of people
like it but more in the future
I think there will be many opportunities and I hope that more people will
enjoy and see more Korean content that is titled as a haircut now i've
got a quota 2 quest l sap
when playing well or fect scasi ms
game arm 400  People write belly harpy
bowa sin
air conditioner Mr. man make big mac
mxr sports ring, there are a lot of books
web page beauty chap for man win qs yoon
just
forget that it really depends on what uh
uh content it is
In my opinion,
it will be more convenient to use , and
people can see more convenient
content and see the content they want
,
and I hope to see a lot of projects in other countries that are becoming more and more popular titles in
Korea
.  Because of this
, I am very familiar with sub-titles,
but there are still many people in the US who are not familiar with sub-titles, but I think this will gradually become a
nipple.
like this - yes